all right we are live slash point II
bonta's in the morning edition not to
bad weather it's better than yours right
now but it didn't sound like I won the
breakfast war so it's a fair trader you
know what do ports it is whatever that
we got right now Jersey tri-state oh man
we got sleet we got ray all it man right
now no I'll take mine I'm good yeah a
little bit a little bit more changes in
the button in the world of bungee and
destiny to again so Before we jump in
anything else you've been up to and you
little blips you got going on really I
mean for the most part it's been you
know waiting to see what's been going on
with Destin but I got some games I've
been playing Oh Ohio fetus week but um
yeah yeah X go to oh I dropped a 4k
update for the Xbox one X and yeah XCOM
has always been one of my favorite
franchises of all time and then what has
happened is the problem that the game
said the low times were kind of brutal
and it was just you know it was just a
lot of slowdown in certain parts cuz
there's so much going on in the sequel
yeah but I must admit it runs nice oh
it's like the my addiction I started all
over again things that happened when
Jesse's not doing with destiny supposed
to do but I was like and I think that's
one of those things that part of the
people that were so hooked on that for
so long didn't play anything else yes so
mad that they have to go look for
something else and sometimes it's okay
and Bungie has said that there's no you
know but I mean destiny twos got a lot
of stuff to fix but if you do want to
take a break that is okay and that's
literally what these times are for like
like it's gonna be there you're right
but like like you said it's one of those
things that it's like it becomes routine
it's like it's what you're used to so
it's like you feel weird
with your that when you used to playing
that one thing or doing that one
activity holder job
yeah I mean we have put we've got 150
hours a monster hunter so far and I've
been now some of that I feel like is
like Asian I'll leave it on so I
probably have like yeah maybe 130 I
probably don't listen to that much but I
played a lot now played a lot but I've
had a lot of fun and that's a game when
it comes to in the game that oh man if
it's like no no game is perfect there's
things that wrong with it the way the
story and multiplayer is so broken in
that game like the way you'd have to try
and get into yeah thorry quest and that
game is terrible like it I don't even
know how that got out the door but on
the other end the level of in-game and
the multiple tiers of things that you
keep having to be able to go after
please just a small piece of that for
what we could go for it would be amazing
I mean and that's a game where stats
don't matter but gear is everything and
there's tears and levels and you keep
going after more and then they've got
like a final tier to go for and then
link and I just learned after you go for
it for a while and what the grind longer
then there's this final addition it's
like there's things to go for and they
keep having like weekly quests in there
just playing you know you're still
fighting the same monsters you're still
going through the same areas but it just
it still feels fun to me and yeah it's
probably fresh I haven't played 2,000
hours of this like I did destiny one but
I've really had fun now the other one I
saw on Twitter and I literally just had
to go to steam and buy it I don't really
I'm gonna play it would you get Chrono
Trigger dropped on oh can I save you
though I heard bad things don't do it I
mean I've heard horror stories out out -
oh my god mr. negative in the SDG sea
podcast they just talked about it on
yesterday and people like people's time
I went from yay - oh no oh my god is it
like two tiki torches would be like this
is the worst part ever
yeah B I'm telling you right now I
literally just heard about that game
like I would wait a second but I'll look
up before I open it up on 3ds and I know
that's a pretty solid version from what
I know it's I mean it's through Nintendo
but like on Steam forever but yeah I
just saw that it dropped out of No
we're knows like that's actually pretty
cool I'm actually cool dat it actually
dropped that is that I mean Crone she's
a classic no that's why it's probably my
favorite RPG of all time so nice hooked
on played through and just the way the
fighting system works in the game but
teaming up the duo and triple attacks
like it's it was always so unique and
joy did so oh yeah people talk about
Chrono Trigger with such high regard
like it's a it's a top RPG you know I
wanted one of the classics one of the
legends but yeah monsters got me you got
XCOM you got a little kingdom come as
well deliveries those are the two man my
life is like I'm waiting for destiny to
do something and that's like it's kind
of where part of this discussion is
going as we get these updates as we get
little patches we've got the February
patch now which we'll talk about and
things may get a little bit things may
be coming not everything's quite what
you think it will be at first and that's
kind of why it's like it will be okay to
look for these things because some
people are gonna wait for the bigger and
bigger things to try and pull them back
but as our guest previously his recent
article he had out there his biggest
thing is that it's not gonna be the big
pet the big expansion that pulls people
back it's gonna be if the game is in a
good place when something like that
comes out so they do when they say fall
and things like that that's why I would
rather have the fall update be its own
thing and the expansion push the
expansion back and get it and again as
we've said or at least I've said I don't
think you agree it's like get it right
like have the game at a place where
people are like okay we're thinking
about coming back things feel good we
got some good stuff coming so but it's
just gonna take a little while but we
will definitely keep you guys tuned so
that rambling aside let's jump into this
week at Bungie so to no one's surprise
new monarchy one lonely fideo
literally like I didn't I was like I
haven't played too much but I was like I
made sure it got on both systems and had
one character at least a new monarchy
one on dead orbit I didn't even worry
about future and pork that's just fine
so sorry future yo I'm surprised future
Wilco hasn't won one faction they've
given them garbage like every time like
even if the perks are like mediocre on
all of them they get the crap end of
mediocre daddies too I mean you had
rampage on the new monarchy Scout right
our pulse rifles like yeah that was the
best of the three that's another big
surprise and honestly the armor kind of
looks cool but yes well by us they're
only I mean if you like yeah I even got
the armor and played with my friend for
just a second chatter he's like that
actually looks that's like one of the
better ones I've seen I'm like I know
like it stands out and it's cool and
this is yeah that'll take me back to
monster it's like not everything is
completely different and now it's like
if you take the fidelity of like destiny
to on PC which is immaculate like so
good and I had monster hunter at that
fidelity oh my god I'm done I'm just
absolutely out world it looks amazing so
absolutely but that's the same idea it's
like when you take armor sets like this
it's like they're okay but even like you
you know that still say he's like okay
it's fine there's another we get a lot
of paid jobs right now so yeah this one
looks a little cooler than some but like
there's still all the same skins like
you guys model up and make news laughs
new monarchy needs something like if
it's a lion I want a lion on my shoulder
I want like you know if the have the
month you like a lion tail have the
chest be like a mane like maybe some
kind of badass looking that's related to
that and there's a little that orbit
you're literally dead some bones like
yeah I'ma be real with you I'm not
feeling the dead orbit looks like a
white brush stroke like that's all about
everything and I'm going that that's all
we get like mmm-hmm I had fun and paint
was just like whoosh and okay more than
that so I don't want it if there's a
bunch of personal this is that please I
don't actually mean that but comparison
like the new monarchy ornate like lion
gold glass and if you really think about
it not to cut you but it's like Newmark
is the only one I feel they got a
complete revamp from do you want I feel
like the other two not that they didn't
get the obviously of what they made
changes but I just to me Tamaki stands
out so much aesthetically that they
really put their time into it as opposed
to the other two factions if you made
like if you gave them truly a theme like
I mean it fer extremity is per se if you
had more of like a death tone I mean
running you that because dead orbit like
you've become dead but if you have like
a skull or things like that on there
people like that kind of looks cool and
then say you gave future war cult just
like even if it's just like neon lights
for where she sit and relax should be
sitting up there anyway like make it a
little kind of crazy and glowing like if
you made a more extreme I think that's
as opposed to everything being so subtle
and kind of dull yeah facts totally so
makes us stand out more so let's say one
so it is a thousand dollars for your I
honestly forget what the reward is I
know I picked it up I I think pick it up
is it was it worth fifty thousand do you
need to go grind for it I've heard
probably not but it is if it's for a
grand you may as well pick it up add it
to your collection so absolutely well I
guess we'll see if new monarchy is gonna
keep it going or if there's somebody
who's making the perks on those guns
gets a little creative at some point
gonna have to hook up future war cause
time Oh coming next we've got on March 6
that we've got iron banner it is clash
this is probably the last iron banner
before it gets its change which we'll
get here in a minute
still 4v4 right now just clash looks
like we're gonna have it looks like a
serves if I guess it's a pulse but I
guess you got nice little grenade
launcher there I mean these at least
have like at least iron banner has it's
kind of unique themes to it but I still
even in Destiny one they had them like
kind of wrapped in like you know the
rope or the cloth or things like that or
just I don't know I feel like they've
tamed a lot of stuff down so yeah cuz
it's all the same models and they're
just reskin there so that's mostly white
but angry they look cold oh I mean I
like Rene launched to look cool was that
a scout at the bottom or it's uh yeah
tell it that stock but yeah I didn't
look him up but I'm not gonna go dig in
the database at this point on they're
not going anywhere but I mean it looks
pretty cool I mean the but unfortunately
it's like we know we could probably go
through and be like yeah we know exactly
what guns are modeled after cuz the skin
the frame doesn't change just the ski
it'd be nice to see a little bit more
just you know make a real set they gotta
get more unique with the with the action
weapon
you know designer models they they read
they're repeating them out even though
like the skins oh god back skins mean
those look tough but they like you said
those are definitely three that guns
that we've seen before so I like the
service one over here looks like it came
straight d1 as well it's like when I got
that and this will bring up other topics
too but it's like when I got my PD x45
with like my perfect range and stability
build a nothing oh and PvP like rivaled
just about everything if not almost I
love that one so if you didn't finish
your challenges those are coming back so
L they're throughout the whole season so
if you didn't get your ornaments unlock
things like that you can still work on
those apparently they said so start
punching everyone so you can get that
chest ornament that's definitely yeah
it's the rough one I've trained yeah
it's like I'm probably gonna be okay for
me if I actually worked on it and
grinded for it I do enough punching I
probably kind of accidentally do but
sure ah but as I said they're like
crucible changes are coming to iron
Manor so I'll give you more specifics
very soon as in now so literally the
next paragraph in the article can I like
the little joke there so so the
aforementioned future crucible plans so
oh God Derrick Carol I'm gonna drop some
knowledge on us about what to expect
with one point one point four and some
of the stuff they've been talking about
with crucible so first thing iron banner
is changing we knew that was coming yes
6v6 that's what I'm talking about let's
go I'm gonna shame at dis 1-866 though
yeah I know we're one way but yes is
your last uh last one otherwise wait for
you know about a month from now and
you'll probably be sitting pretty a
match limit is the match time limit is
twelve minutes score limit is 125 points
which feels I think what supremacy is
probably about the same something like
that respawn time is seven seconds which
feels long
maybe it's not I haven't actually timed
it in a while but that sounds long in my
head but maybe it's not this is cool and
they're kind of going back to d1 a
little bit more just on lots of things
we've got all control zone start off
neutral take slightly longer to capture
and if you have additional guardians max
of three so half your team the zone is
captured quicker so literally all school
old school d1 right there all those last
three boum boum boum all do you I've
never understood that whole change they
did when they initially started d2 with
the whole you know a and C already yours
you know and then B just fighting for B
you know I mean I didn't despise it but
I was always curious as to again why the
need was change I didn't understand that
a lot of you had it you had two options
you to run other straight for theirs and
you likewise convert it and basically
flip them and have to instantly now
you've at least got to leave one person
even if they capture it slow or leave
one back maybe and then figure out if
you're gonna go for theirs if you're
gonna go for B either way you've got a
you know find your way to hold to so
yeah I think that'll be hopefully a nice
refreshing change I'm curious how 6v6
feels in this because now with the you
know multiple people on his own there's
incentive to have more people in there
so maybe supers can have a little bit
more of that you know a glass multi kill
situation which we kind of miss a lot of
Thessaly and a little police also
speaking supers if you participate in a
capture which is gonna give you more
incentive to hopefully go play the
points which is right what kind of
methods control yep you get more super
energy when you do now I don't know how
much that's gonna be how much would you
like to see um I mean I played was it
the aren't what's called control last
I'm banner yeah and it was it was a very
small amount I mean it gives you
something but it was a smidgen so um you
know I don't know how to to was it to
rank it as far as on you look quantified
much of your bar like would you want
like a quarter a half like a tenth like
a lot or a little like how much do you
think when you sit there and you hit
capture and you're like you get capture
points like how much do you think that
bar should move if you're getting a cab
say like a quarter the only reason I
mean cuz you do a lot of caps in the
course of a game
so I mean listen if they made it more
than a quarter I wouldn't be upset you
know she's obviously gonna be more
supers and more super sis always fun you
know I'm saying at the same time I don't
want it to get mayhem level crazy
because we have mayhem for that so it's
like I mean to be honest even if it is a
lot I guess I wouldn't be mad you know
if they did that what's your feeling on
it I was like I'm kind of I'm with you
I'm like kind of the more the merrier to
a point but it's like I think I like the
idea behind this because it gives you
incentive to go to give people a reason
to be like I'm not just gonna go fight
over B and beat my head against I'm
gonna be like I'm gonna take half the
team and go run to the one that's not
under mayhem right now and go try and
steal there so I can get super and go
work around and make be from like excuse
me so I mean for me if it was because I
mean I try and think when you see like
when you look at the stats at the end
like how many captures did you have
I usually probably see like the upper
and is probably like six or seven I
think right because I mean once you kind
of get them settled they don't shift as
much unless you're really just like the
two teams who play against each other
heard like rotate the entire time and
not all of them do that but if you go
six or seven and you if you're like high
up and you get your super say twice from
doing that if you get it like maybe a
third or a quarter like a decent chunk
then I'm okay with that because you're
actually playing the game mode and
you're getting and you're getting to
have a little bit more fun with it I
think yeah spreads the supers out so not
everybody gets him at the same time
alone axing I like that you made a great
point a lot of that now that you broke
it down that way that's actually a
fantastic point and to meet a huge thing
is I love that it's rewarding the
objective so that you know in an
objective based game that's what you
kind of want game mode that's the time
and to me that just the the teamwork
element of more people on the point
making it capture faster I'm all about
that positive changes like honestly I
wish all of these would be a normal
control manner very true I mean I think
this maybe build out their devil and if
people like it
and I guess we'll see I don't know what
the numbers are like and what they're
you know playerbase is looking at to
test their numbers but I'd love to see
control looks like this all the time
because all these things seem positive
to me like the time those pieces I don't
know the score for six people those are
fine but literally just the zone
starting from the last four bullet
points here take them all over to the
other control and then that will I you
know that make it feel better
but here's the question if they've been
thinking about this they've been testing
it for a little while
be like hey these are some of the
changes we're thinking about we're gonna
change up control to these four things
have them active now and what's out
there and if you guys are playing
control hey give us some feedback while
we're doing this this is what we're
looking at fire and banner the if these
are the tests the changes they've been
thinking about maybe on one of their hot
fixers if something make control be this
for a couple of weeks and then you'll
have an idea before you launch on your
banner oh good point
it's not a test server but it'd be like
these are things they've obviously
thought about they've been testing since
they're official now just let let go of
the reins a little bit and let us test
them out for you like throw just those
last four before in there see how it
feels
I agree I agree at the same time I also
still want it to be i rather than be a
differentiate and i think i guess the
way that my look is six is i think right
you think six is gonna be the main
differentiator that's to be like we're I
guess to make Iron Man are different cuz
I haven't heard six as mentioned
anywhere else it still seems fours
doubles come on get to the other nice
little bonus here in a second but yeah I
guess iron banner 6v6 is that's a way to
make it different mm-hmm for I mean
these are these sound great so I mean he
gives me even more incentive to play
iron banner because I think it sounds
like it's gonna be more fun so yeah yeah
the one in the back run and points I'm
like wow super woo super like it's fine
with it like it's kind of part of it
yeah next one they felt like dropping a
little nugget for us here rumble will
make its triumphant return so we talked
about the crucible playlist that will be
coming back and they said no excuses no
complications absolutely no points four
assists so you you get what you kill and
that's it yeah you get a single point
per kill just like in the golden
individual game it's one for one there's
not a hundred points for this bad it's
literally you get a kill two you're at
one
oh oh by the way it's eight players this
time
that's huge like I like that I like that
cuz even even deep no that's that's even
more in there and some of these maps are
there built fairly smaller at least for
the ones we've got because they are 4v4
they're not quite 266 there's definitely
nothing like first light or sky watch
those massive maps most of them are not
quite to the asylum level but they're
definitely not even in the medium range
like burning Charon is probably a decent
comparison and it's not a huge amount
per se like Pantheon I feel like that's
a longer one or it takes farther to get
between sides and stuff like that so I
think with eight people in there it's
gonna be pretty chaotic absolutely I
actually got excited about that remember
I'm the PvP so shall I take risk over
late in the chat things like more for me
to kill with the AP were I mean that got
me excited because the problem with the
current meta as the crucible guy the
problem with the current meta right now
is that it's too teen shot related and
so you need to be able to lone wolf and
have Rumble back with eight and I can
see a little bit of chaos but it also is
gonna it's gonna get back to the
one-on-one gameplay now yeah you're
gonna get team shot shot by like other
Guardians and crossfire stuff like that
house fire don't happen yeah that's
gonna happen you know I'm saying but at
the end of the day it's gonna come down
for the most part more of those
one-on-one engagements and who's got the
better gun skill so to speak and that
kind of excites me and just ate in there
that's dope and we're gonna talk about
what else they're gonna do with these
modes as we continue but I'm excited
about this actually I do like this a lot
I wish we can have a rumble I wish we
could add it in January because I know
so many people complain about the
balance of PvP and I understand like the
time to kill slower and things like that
but it's due to the whole team shot
mechanic things are skewed and however
you look at it but if you do a
one-on-one that's the way I think you
would feel more test your balance and
weapons and that's I would lie would
just just give me a rumble now cuz I
want to know how those one-on-ones feel
if I'm like I'm going with better devils
right now and I'm just getting worked by
an auto rifle constant hey maybe it's
not the best or so I mean those
one-on-ones as you're saying I came out
wait for those because if nothing else
it's a way for you to hone your own
skill that's what made me a better
crucible player because what what
happened is I had my lineup sight you
know and I have a kid I need let me
bring you know the last word I know I'll
bring this gun or whatever
a legendary anon scout and I'm trying
different thing and then also per map
this from maps that play better to sort
of weapon types means so it's like at
the end of day was it made me say okay
you know what
this doctrine a person anyway elective
of how good certain guns were you that's
when the meta starts to formulate you
know but it's hard in this team shot
matter because everyone's sticking
together you get killed by by two guys
you don't really know what's working you
know me right
yeah I mean cuz even if like even if I
get the drop if they just shift people
behind the wall and come back out I'm
working on a new health bar and I'm
still trying to kill somebody and I'm at
a disadvantage no matter what and as
their a little slower if they get they
if they have more health at the start of
the fight I'm done no I'm can looking
forward to this it'd be I think it'll be
a great way for us to get a better feel
for what the men is actually like so we
probably still know which guns are
pretty good but the one on once will
make things shine and not shine a little
bit more extreme facts so mayhem is
still mayhem which that's kind of a all
on its own that's kind of a obvious
statement but basically they're saying
these three modes will share a central
location in the crucible director and
they're gonna rotate so now finally
getting the weekly featured players come
back she's gotta bring that back freedom
X they they see coming back oh man this
is what I'm talking about like this is
my d1 life I've logged in on that
Tuesday you had your nightfall you had
all the stuff you had to do then that
lower left-hand corner you had those
four or five beings activities that you
can get reward from from chests doing
crucible and to have now call of arms
right we assuming that's gonna be
separate hopefully
and now these molds in the crucible
director page from a playlist that's
gonna look like it rotates this is what
I'm talking about you gotta give the
crucible guy because at the end of the
day and I used to go into this with a
lord zero a lot is that as great as
destiny is when it's great right when
the PV is great three hungry when you
have those loaves crucible and trousers
with keep this things alive man I mean
it's like you'll there's a point where
people burn out on some of the other
stuff put PVCs that's why people like
nothing but Call of Duty is the story
takes like six hours but they played you
know 200 hours of BB beat no Gabriel so
we still hype the stuff they give them
back from Bheema
yes we're just trying to get things that
we want back in the game where they come
from or where they were before
believe me it's like we understand they
were there and it's like that's probably
one of the biggest things I'll even sit
there and talk to my wife about it and
be like so you took three years to learn
I'll learn a whole bunch of things from
destiny too or destiny and then you have
destiny to release and you're going
where's all the stuff like what happened
you guys like it's like they were
working in two different little like
timelines and they didn't talk to each
other yes and I don't understand that's
one of those that's why I want to sit
down I wish it was like did it was it 16
months did you have to redevelop this
did you get shortened on time or their
pusher pressures from here did you have
to like like I don't know but when all
these things are like hey we're
listening here hey we're doing this hey
we're bringing this back it's like
thanks thanks thanks thanks but I was
like I can't even go play a story
mission I want to play how is that how
are those like not there I don't this
yeah so we've talked about that before I
won't die but digress too much okay but
no absolutely understand it's like are
we excited about stuff from d1 coming
back yeah
should they've been there yeah I mean
it's that's kinda how that goes give us
back the stuff we had years to make a
good game like did why like if it ain't
broke don't fix it and shout out to Doc
shout out the docs article that was the
last blip it is absolutely you gotta
check out the new one shout that he's
got a new one up we're gonna talk about
he's actually he's given suggestions on
it it's long on how to save it and it's
a really
I'm probably most likely put the link in
the description so guys to check him
back he's gonna break the internet again
moving on we've got doubles which was
Cruz the Crimson playlist they said it's
an it's chrysalis so as you guys imagine
a caterpillar turning into a butterfly
it's got its in-between stage it's uh
it's changing so they basically say it's
gonna turn into its beautiful butterfly
metaphors analogies cheesy and what but
they do say they want to give a little
more powers a little more flexibility
they're just gonna want that mode you
know probably be tweaked and they
probably also want to figure out how to
stop you know in finishing it was vowed
remains an infinite like being invisible
pretty much the hunters you guys very
much
we're gonna have a doubles playlist of
just hunters you guys can go beat the
hell out of each other and we're gonna
have warlocks and Titans over here have
a normal doubles being like you guys are
crazy
we're over here on this other play they
will actually have the Crimson double
mechanic in doubles which is like what
the abilities and stuff we charge for
actually when you guys go hope so and I
think that's where like the polish and
flexibility maybe they need to balance
the charge sign but I think that's why
people who did play it enjoyed it again
it's another type of variety to it if
you want doubles I mean maybe you make
and here here's another thing maybe
doubles has the mechanic maybe you bring
back things like oh one thing inferno no
no facts double comes back it's no map
it's no buffs but it's still just you
want to do hardcore like yeah to inferno
was you want to learn how to play this
game differently when you live off of a
radar take that radar away I like that I
love that I love when they did spooky
trials like that to remember oh oh yes
it was really cool let's bring it back
to skill let's have molds without that
radar that's and I think this is where I
heard I heard it somewhere I forget who
was saying it but that whole it I think
you must follow a place actually I was
listening one of his videos when it
comes to crucible and when it comes to
private matches it cannot just be hey oh
and play this game mode on the
that is not what private matches should
be I said it before we want to be able
to customize as he's saying it's like
take that mechanic's room doubles let us
turn it on maybe it's like and then he
said hey maybe you flip it maybe your
fear a certain distance from somebody
and I think it was yeah I'm pretty sure
it's fall out on this one so I just
wanna make sure I'm given the right
source but maybe you flip it if you're
farther away you get a buff maybe if
you're together you can see the
waypoints but if you split up from your
teammate maybe you drop off the map and
then maybe you get a buff that way like
yeah well thatís exit I know that's a
little harder to program per se but I
like let us like turn on you know you
know it does proximity ability charging
have that me like a radio button you can
turn on mayhem mode how what level of a
him be like yes a person 200 percent a
thousand percent make it like really
stupid but I mean and then turn on what
guns you can and can't have be like just
hand cannons and sniper rifles like just
let us have some fun and mix up the
choices we want and that's where I think
people who used to do like Halo matches
in custom matches and you have an entire
mode of dota that came out of people
creating their own stuff let the
community make some things and then when
you guys see something that's really
good okay take it and you know Bungie if
I it and make it like polished then
really set us a new mode mmm I'm rich
yeah I'm absolutely would you let let us
gold wild what the options in the
customization and then in the variety
and diversity you know I'm like let us
go walk well with it
and shot the game at it yes there's no
excuse what PvP custom matches should
agree yeah that well that wasn't even at
launch so but hey if if they don't put
it in and it's not you know the because
I thought destiny one private matches
were useless to unless you just many
firms of specific people in there and he
didn't do anything for me either so if
they're gonna put more features in it
great if it's just the same thing yeah
give it to us now like yeah that's so so
that's most of crucible so we've got
things to look forward to there will be
other features coming with one point one
point four which is the big sandbox
updates they said they're gonna make
everybody's lives better unless their
habitual quitters so they're still
working on the cheating good the
quitters and things like that so
positive stuff coming another little
if it is March 27th when that's coming
so we've got you know 25 days couple
more of these updates one point one
point four is to one a link for a baby
you know
so yeah hopefully Crucible is you know I
like that there again they're going back
to d1 but that's what a lot of people
want so at least these sound like
positive changes towards that direction
so absolutely more and more good things
so next we come to the nightfall scoring
QA now I'll have some thoughts on this
one but so scoring went live on Tuesday
and they said they're gonna monitor the
initial feedback and see about tiers and
scores and things like that so a couple
of things the emblems are out there so
your emblem for the nightfall that you
get is gonna be showing your score what
the threshold is to get the aura things
like that are gonna be on there also
there's different variants for the
nightfall so once you complete it to a
certain level you can get like a
slightly different emblems kind of nice
to have some modifications to it
and they said I guess the chance will be
from zero to fifty percent I guess each
run so I mean there's a little incentive
but again this is where we need the
nightfall rewards to give me real
incentive to run it if I just get like a
different slightly looking emblem I
don't look at my emblem half the time so
if it's just slightly different that's
not gonna make me go run the nightfall
again I agree yeah it kind of took me
out the game without be honest too but
it's like when I looked at when when it
came out the patch came out went
straight to your video let me see you
Hannibal each of the cactus I watched
his video as well and I'm just like this
emblem stuff is not doing it for me bro
yeah because I mean I think I put the
blip in there about etz same thing so
yeah but we're gonna deep dive into that
continue on but yeah it's just it's not
enough and it's a shame because Ramon we
talked about was it yeah one point one
point three you know I thought we were
gonna get the rewards in conjunction
right and they got the lip so they could
polish yeah that that took that you know
you took the carrot away and I'm just
like there's another piece that will
come to it later but they changed like
one or two things which I'll cover in
the nightfall itself be it for people
who thought there
they wanted to do it solo and things
like that the I was like we'll get to it
but they also mentioned for the variants
there's different tiers of the variants
and they say the scores say right now
and it holds for the different variants
and you only get a chance as well but
it's 20,000 40,000 60,000 80,000 right
to get a decent score I can tell you now
you're gonna be running prestige for
sure because the modifiers your score is
pretty garbage even solo like and
whether I haven't even finished it yet
which is one thing I'll get to here in a
second but the fact that you have to do
prestige to get some of these things the
regular nightfall kind of feels a little
empty er I guess yes
so they took oh they took some things
away and then the normal night follows
almost less incentive but you have to I
think we run the normal night fault to
go get the card okay so you got to run
it to get the card then we run the
procedure then you have to run it again
but I think the card at least to get the
scoring so I that's why I was like I
need to finish the damn nightfall which
is what I'm gonna work on today but I'll
cover why I'm having some struggles with
that esoteric still nailed it dudes
crushing and I know there's a couple
people that have but I was trying the
other night and there's a reason it's
rough so next we look at this oh
somebody has to question why are the
tears so they want the 20 40 60 80 for
example not visible in game basically
the thing they're going to see what
people do in the world they set the
current threshold for the aura at sixty
thousand you're not gonna touch that for
one in normal and you definitely need a
decent chunk of modifiers to get there
as well so you're gonna have to earn it
which I'm kind of okay with you are
gonna have to play pretty well to get
these things but on the other ends they
just they they don't want to show them
and I don't know like if you know what
it is when the when it launches that
week even if it's just like a little
like you know a hotfix patch it takes
like two seconds to download on Tuesday
once the resets done have that be the
update and then when you get the card
you can actually see the ores because at
least it gives you a goal if you don't
know what you're going for and you can't
see it again the transparency guys let
us know what's out there so I just I
wish they would show it more even if
it's just you know numbers and a next
week they're gonna change but this is
what it is this week we at least know
then you know somebody gets a card it
would give
you know people a little more incentive
to get the card be like okay hey I want
to get that envelope I think that third
one looks cool I just want to make sure
you get there maybe they don't have to
turn on all the modifiers to do it but
otherwise they turn everything on make
it as hard as possible they're beating
their head against the wall but they
didn't get the one they wanted so it'd
be nice to know I feel like I'm talking
a lot today so feel free to chime in
whatever I love it alright so I've got
my thoughts on this one so I'm going to
let you jump in first because this kind
of wraps the nightfall so why were
nightfall modifiers removed
yeah what's that first cuz I got my
thought so I'm gonna again it's like I
really wanted to get excited about one
point one point three but this uh I mean
they say the removal of the base
modifiers from night falls because we
want to emphasize quarter combat in this
initial release and let the community to
scream from the mountaintops
I want Korra combat no matter who is
this for like that's what I was feeling
why take away things that people like
there's no clamoring for this so I just
don't understand this design choice I
appreciate that the transparency ol
budget even got that sentence right we
would have been taken away and we don't
know why and then you know you wait till
it comes back till they talk about it
coming back but um yeah they say they're
gonna revisit the modifiers in the
future they're not dead and buried open
the player back so they play a feedback
so they're not dead and buried but
they're not here there's no real reason
besides this quote-unquote core combat
this is a misstep I didn't like that I
didn't I mean that's what makes things
exciting you know I'm saying having that
modify having those different burns
having I don't know jumping I don't know
no I mean I'm in the absolutely same
sentiment I literally logged in doing my
weekly reset video going through and I
had to literally like cut it and start
it again because I went in there and I
looked the Knights all and I'm going
with
hold on the modifiers are gone guys like
I know the timer's were going away
modifiers were going to leave so killing
time anomalies things like that we're
gonna go away that I can kind of
understand but you've got stuff like
torrent to give you a nice bonus make
the week maybe a little easier for some
then you'll have things like momentum
that gets to be a pain in the butt so
that you've got a challenge week but at
least it gives it variety no other
strikes have modifiers so now literally
fight like regulars heroics and the
normal nightfall has no modifications to
it so you're literally running the same
three strikes it just feels like the nut
regular nightfall got cranked up to
heroic and I'm getting my butt kicked
yep cuz we don't ever feel powerful
which is a whole different problem
mm-hmm but the only way is the prestige
like and I'm not saying it's not a bad
thing to have modifiers on the hardest
one because you know you get a challenge
in there but it's like don't take it
away from the other one what are you
doing what are you doing again it's the
same thing with the scoring in in the
sense of okay you got it and I fall but
you don't why is it not in the strike
stuff you know I'm saying like their
work site it's just easier decisions
sometimes I just get it you know the
list felt pretty curated before it
always seemed to be there may have been
two different sets of modifiers for any
given strikes since d2 released they
never to have they never seemed to be
there were certain ones that would never
get momentum or there ones that would
just seemingly never have torrent on
them like torrents because it was
positive but there were certain ones
that only had certain modifier
combinations on them and they never like
I don't think anomalies was ever they
never put that obviously in curse at my
Cyrus these I'm always modifier who's
never in there
so they've curated those modifiers to
know which ones go where which ones we
want so therefore you got and they say
that hey they do internal playtesting
that's where these thresholds come from
do the internal play testing with the
modifiers and you have an idea what the
number is gonna be where's the thing
exactly at the worst case you tweak it
after the fact but it's like why try to
be my father and say this is why
I'm into playing the core game with no
fun and like but like towards lunch not
about phrase right there but seriously
it's like why do you have to take
biggest question why remove the fun if
we're not if torrent is gone for a while
and the only thing we get is that Bert's
Inge burn because the other two
modifiers make it harder said you know
it was one that gives you a bonus mm-hmm
well it reminds me of Doc's article
whack-a-mole
yes that's literate and they workable
this is bundling whack-a-mole yeah okay
you guys are having fun with like
modifiers in torrent okay we're gonna go
back to base nightfall there's no reason
why you can't have torrent beyond one
week it'd be like okay that's a higher
score threshold you have play testers in
there I know there's tests and other
stuff have one or two groups or in the
nightfall a few times get a gauge and
run with the number it doesn't have to
be perfect the first week feel it out
it's fine then you have you know
momentum another week okay this one's
harder this is a lower score threshold
that's fine but it gives variety to it
mix it up on the weeks that way like you
know you know I got content creators and
I'm not saying we need content but we
desk most of them desperately do if you
run a nightfall and you're going hey
this week we got torrent the scores are
higher but you don't work with your team
use those you know use them more okay
this week we've got momentum just
because that one's harder you've got
those little you have to keep moving so
it's definitely one where you gotta be a
little more mobile
just like adjust according to that like
you've got the ones in there and you
also have modifiers that are in the
adventures which there's no thing here
it says we're currently investigating
you or heroic modify heroic adventure
modifiers do not appear for some players
yeah so they have other modifiers which
actually a couple of those were kind of
cool there was like melees or more if
you're closer or grenades do more damage
or one with supers do more damage I'm
like where are those modifiers yeah
where were you being in yeah Rotato
through like just just give us four you
have content say Marie I'll go back to
Monster Hunter because I've been playing
a buttload of it but it works a pretty
decent reference right now and I kind of
want to do a video of and I'm sure
people have of what it could learn but
what most any game could learn from
other games is like nobody's perfect but
there are certain things they do right
and if you have content you
in different ways biggest things more
not completely man completely agree yeah
it hurt on wagon all Papa bungee body
what fun is for us but no so the
challenge cards the way they work you've
got the option to die and go all the way
back to orbit but that will if your
whole team dies if you're doing it solo
well you get one life so you're not
gotta go flawless you've got the option
to basically tick up the amount of your
level that you want deducted so
obviously for prestige you want to be
330 so 335 is where you're gonna be but
you can lower up to 40 points of your
level to go from 335 to 295 in theory at
least so that will give you more points
on top the other one to add is the tsuge
and you can choose either art kavod or
solar it really depends on who you're
going for the infinite forest has
everything so it's kind of a gamble but
in the end you've got mostly cabal so
cabal and Becks are gonna be your main
two that you're gonna face there so plan
accordingly from what I heard art was
probably reasonable when to pick or
avoid actually no I think void was the
good one to pick this week but you can
pick it and yeah you get you know a
little bit of a burn I think it's like
25% more going both ways so they can do
more damage to you as well so I mean
those are okay but again it's only from
the cards you can choose it but they
don't give us too many options and they
did say this is my nightfall you know
challenge cards 0.9 so they do hopefully
want to add more to that but I'm like
you better fix the normal nightfall -
absolutely happening now one other thing
that changed and it was one thing that
if you were doing a regular strike you
noticed and I don't know why they
changed this for the night phone cause
it was already hard enough in the time
limits there when you died in the
previous night falls you just have a
timer even if you were solo you would
sit there wait for the timer to go and
then you would have respawn where you're
at in the same instance the you know
enemies have the same health to boss
that's the same else you could keep
working it down potentially and that's
what I was actually thinking it would be
going forward the way normal and heroic
strikes work if your team wipes say on a
boss run you start the whole boss Rover
that's how the nightfall
mmm so it's checkpoints and if you wipe
it's not a timer to restart you go back
and you start the whole checkpoint again
so this week it is the tree of
possibility strike with the big cabal
Centurion in the end he's a beast he's
amazed he said he's trying to run this
thing solo like if you make it through
two of the rooms but you die in the
third you got to start it all over now I
know this feels more like dusty one
because that's kinda how it worked if
you failed the boss room you had to
start it over a crazy go to Davos and
you decided the only one with phases
which is annoying yeah but yeah if you
go through a certain section even like
the infinite forest if you're going
through there trying to go fast and
begin the infinite forest they want it
to incentivize you for killing
everything right yeah that was the big
thing so when I go through and I try and
kill everything and I'm going solo for
example I know they still want this to
be a group activity but it's not much
made so don't force it when I go through
and Sol LeWitt I don't even finish the
if I want to kill everything
I barely would even get out of the
infinite forest before that timer was
done if I want to kill everything Wow
though like I'll go I mean I can put up
a night fail video instead of a
nightfall I did one of those back in b1
and I got some hilarious comments out of
that but yeah it really might nightfall
failure because you guys could watch me
be like uh nope Nomad oh it's just all
of those pieces where if you were some
people like hey I want to do solos like
he didn't get easier I mean if you had
the timer and you had to do it fine you
wouldn't lose horn you lose it but you
couldn't work your way that is true yeah
you're right note that it that is
absolutely true and I'm not saying I
won't do it and it's like trust me we're
gonna go try and beat my head against
that wall here a little while because I
do want to still do it because I've seen
others do it and I know it's feasible
but in that room you've got a pretty
small box and it kind of takes me back
to why does every strike have to be a
place where I can't hide but you have
people they don't miss yes the accuracy
uncanny and there's no way to really get
kind of hunker down like scions up top
that are sniping me on top of everything
else and they really don't miss and they
kind of hurt so it's like I'm running
around the room it's like I figured out
the first
kind of got that one going second rooms
getting a little dicey but it's like
it's optional then you have the ads come
in on top of trying to avoid him and you
just don't have a lot of places to hide
then the lasers come into the room and
I'm going holy crap so yeah it was a
struggle when I was trying to do that
Tuesday night when I worked but taking
away the modifiers like that at least
makes it more fun taking away the check
like the checkpoints are back so you're
cranking that one back up you've already
got the kick it back to orbit if you
want to man so I don't know it's like
it's it's mmm it's not everything I hope
for and they took stuff away that didn't
seem necessary so I'm hoping they listen
to feedback and because they're either
that why were nightfall what modifiers
removed cuz a lot of people ask yeah
that was addressed but yep oh it's
unfortunate that it was intentional top
score right now is 220 mm just a
buttload that's a lot esoteric for
example I used to him as a kid a
reference because of that dude solo
everything I know he runs with a good
team he I think with max modifiers had
about a hundred and sixty five so that's
still a pretty big gap to the max I mean
shout-out to visa guys they did a hell
of a run so yeah those guys mean that
that's a good run that's a fantastic run
please bring back my damn modifiers the
other thing I kind of get to is the type
of the timer
they said they removed it which is fine
blood it still working against you yeah
it is because they it I mean but I kind
of understand that on some level right
because I don't sit back and get
everything off you know like I do feel
that time should have some bearing on
the score yeah cuz it did indeed one I
remember like you know didn't after a
certain point that you it would kind of
affect a lawyer score or not just games
like I think challenge of elders or
something like that it would if you took
too long on a room it would start
deducting but it was yes it would go
fifty hundred two fifty and give it
would crank up quick this is just like a
constant running deduction so even when
you start and kill a guy you're losing
points instantly
so you're constantly losing so I mean
there's the incentive to go through but
I mean most of the stuff I watched I
mean and some of these guys who got a
high score probably didn't lose much but
I was like most of the guys I watched it
still like even if you get to the you
know the half point if you're running so
well I guess this hurts solo people more
than anything so if you want to run solo
it got really demoralizing more than
anything is no it's the point of when
you get to you'll go 100 percent at 15
minutes you get 50 percent and then at
18 minutes you get no more but I really
wish at that point just because it just
kind of pisses me off every time every
time I kill an enemy it's plus zero plus
zero plus zero you got norm plus zero
and killing enemy plus zero constantly
the entire time once you're done at the
18 minutes yeah that that cats like take
that away like I don't need to see that
like that is demoralizing yeah so it's
just like yeah you suck you're too slow
you're not getting anything else oh sure
I mean people listen to this can be like
Doody bone just get good you used to do
this fine like I got to get my act
together and I totally agree with you
guys like I know I'm better than this
what the hell's going on it's like and
it's fine but yeah it's just kind of one
of those like take the plus hero way
just like you know I don't need that
update on the screen even if you've you
know even if you're running as a group
and you're going a little slower just
take it away like nobody needs to see
that either way I mean so I think it's
perfect
no oh there's yeah there's some some
changes that need to happen I just hope
they're open to feedback because if this
is what they all put together and liked
and ran I do want to run it as a team
unfortunately there's not a whole lot of
people running a lot of stuff right now
but I do want to kind of run as a team
and see how it goes so I will need to do
that to hopefully have a little little
better feedback next week just I've
literally worked Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday so this will be my first chance
to kind of jump in that's it
below that we've got spawning woes so
they talked about kind of a glitch in
the Leviathan where people weren't
spawning and to my surprise they mention
a memory issue and I was like hey wait a
minute
that's familiar with the vault and view
what are we talking about
[Music]
so basically it's at the point where if
you're in the vaults kurtmult you're in
the Leviathan raid and it's basically
saying if you spread yourselves out too
far
apparently the game is trying to handle
I guess it sounds like all of the area
in between and it kind of runs into a
memory capacity issue to a point and you
won't spawn in so it's kind of boring to
spawn or wipe and die and then kind of
get everybody back in it's a weird thing
I've seen and it's more rampant recently
because they've been giving loot in the
raid which is a good thing but then
somebody's gonna be sitting there like
after they finished the dogs like
looking at their armor and moving stuff
around the other people are like halfway
across the map so I understand why it's
just been coming up they said they're
it's you know they just said stick
together and you can try and avoid it
that's not an acceptable fix and they
know it and these are the comments I do
like they're like I do this like those
are some of the things that's like
thanks for being candid we're like we
know that's not real but thanks for
saying this is a way you can't avoid it
if you know if you're you know I respect
that I I've been really respecting them
with the transparency on bugs even
before like they tell us like I know
there's gonna be a bug for this or look
out for that you know that kind of thing
I respect that
if they know it's there and they're like
hey this is there we already literally
have the patch like certified with Sony
and Microsoft he's gonna launch and
we'll hit it with the next hotfix like
we know we're sorry but you know just
stuff to expect the heads-up is nice yes
huge huge I mean it's just it's a baby
step but it's like if you want to build
trust in your community we appreciate
that as opposed to you know here's the
broken gun
we know that guns broken have fun I mean
that's there's two sides to play that
and they've been progressively getting
better so I appreciate it a couple
others speaking of known issues with
11.3 so they said modifiers are
currently not available for some players
on the heroic adventures which is weird
that it some players I haven't actually
tried those yet destiny Emblem
statistics so for example the European
dead zone tracks the number of ghosts
cannibals like whatever weird thing that
you go up and scan get a little bit of
lore out of it's not showing the right
number for the max there's total 41
apparently it's only shown 38
and then they said some scandals found
do not update and total player returns
to orbit so like the cards don't update
on the fly right now since the
prestigious challenge card score
multipliers they have an issue present
on the challenge cards that do Nate
updates do not update properly when
players are selecting cinge modifiers
which is that damage type modifier oh
they're still working on that one you
know transparency I like that
at least I know what what's going on I'm
not going crazy you know even when they
were talking about was it breaking down
master work score or something he said
you know last one so yeah you're like oh
freaking out did it happen no no you're
good exactly
move know what else forget just a little
bit of movie magic and that pretty much
wraps hello
they basically say it's like you know
they've got challenges complete for iron
banner so he's gonna come back work on
your guy's ornaments
it's March so we are within the month of
the one point one point for update so I
know you're you're chomping at the bit
to get to that one hey you know it baby
it's all about one point one point phone
box is gonna be like sandbox is big and
this is on for again it's been since
lunch we haven't to say have it haven't
had a sandbox touch and it's gonna be
six months yeah thanks too long to do
these like they've got to find a way to
make them quicker or be to don't be as
worried about stuff getting unbalanced
just know you can update it you know the
next week be like hey this is the meta
for the week stuffs a little broken have
some fun see you next week it's
different like find a way to do that
quicker and just be more fluid with your
changes it's like they're in a very old
mmm I guess I'm looking over stuff like
you've gonna you know you could do like
Sprint's every couple weeks or like
whatever they're doing like a full six
month planning session and then by the
time you're way too long way too long
and at the end of the day it's like like
you just said I mean let us you know
make some tweaks to the things that
we're complaining about you know you
don't have to go super heavy handed but
at least make some changes and then you
know let the community play around with
it
let the metals meta settle in and then
from there you know you can make it
Justin's according but it's just like
they'd be there so the thing with Bungie
and I believe it shouted I again is like
mentioned wings on show is that there so
data relay you know relevant they rely
on it so much and that's great don't get
me wrong you can see Torino trends and
what's going on and stuff like that but
at the end of the day if your community
says gun X is not fun or that's a lot
yeah you know I have no reason to use
grenade launches like they often a
grenade grenade launcher and I have bad
it's like yeah it looks cool the
aesthetic the skin know what's gonna use
it no one's using it so again at the end
of the day like or even you know what
poll the community they like to you know
poll remember when they pulled um know
what do you want to win get over it you
know whole your community let you know
let listen get directly from the source
and if the source is saying hey you know
you got to do something with you know I
don't wanna keep picking on grenade
launchers but so that's there it's like
the worst weapon class right now it's
like no reason I'm going to do it so you
have to do something you know I mean and
then let it settle you know if everyone
overboard or heavy-handed you pull it
back again but again that it has to be
more frequency there has to be this
waiting six months for a sandbox update
yeah yeah that's not good I mean you've
got so division was an example of too
much with the elites that was one of the
things I noticed because people were
farming division tech and high-end
things and resources and stuff so when
they released like another patch things
were so skewed to the people that had so
much like streamers and things cuz they
play all the time the average person was
kind of screwed you don't have crafting
and things like that in this game but
again as you're saying it's like take
some time input but they still did
frequent updates mm-hmm great
because think about it's like in it the
crews will play I was telling people
like there is no incentive that till at
least as bad as all the other conditions
are right now there's thing right yeah
at least a PvE guy can say hey I got my
six
on the Ray hey I got my three let's run
a night fall you know I mean this no
real you know extensive to continually
play crucible especially when things are
just grouped up in the quick play
competitive you know I'm saying is right
now so it's like I mean I ain't gonna be
all doom and gloom but these are the
things so you so why not shake the met
up for these guys what's the worst
that's gonna happen
so people have fun for a week like laser
tag bring that back by the way
laser tag that was so much fun yep so I
mean that was a lot of fun but it's like
things that were missing give us
incentive to play and you guys are gonna
get tired of hearing about Monster
Hunter but it's still they have they all
but the hell they'll do like weekly
quests like but it's something new
you'll fight different monsters in a
different location or you'll get this
little crazy cosmetic set from doing you
know from farming this quest a couple of
times something like that so same
principle like put some stuff in there
that's just like but I mean as you've
said it before you're what was the big
shacks Mountford nightfall true meaning
of wool in general the daily bounties
and I think Doc mention those two
articles you know the bounties as a
daily reason to play differently a daily
thing to do something different that's
why people would do that I mean there's
a point where I stopped doing bounties
because I probably had so much of
everything I was told but that still
filled up a lot more time that was more
reason to go back and be like hey I want
to knock out these bounties but again we
have to have incentive to go after other
things so I mean there's part of it no I
agree and it just incentivizing you know
shut up about 3:00 a.m. went oh we used
to fight about this and the ones used to
hate pound he's like that you know they
can simplify well they basically did
what he wanted which is basically put it
in almost on a director screen and it
says but it's not specific how the old
bat bounties were now it's a general
thing flashpoint you know our hence name
and show you know you know then you got
you know call arms okay cool
but once that's done there wasn't like
kill the hive on the moon what memory
used to be very specific you know there
is
that was the one of the things he
mentioned well was a reason to play a
different class yes every but like why
Titan I'm never not striker most of the
time like if I was gonna go play eater
of worlds
I know solar is very good for the boss
because of the explosive hammers but
outs that for most things for PDP for
throwing grenades and public events for
most things I run that way if there was
bounty to be like hey go you know go
gets you know whatever it is solar kills
or go get Boyd kills or you know blind
people with your bubble like make
specific things to have people be like
oh this class it's so bad let me play
with it for a little bit it gives people
a reason to go experiment goof around or
just force them to play a different way
for one little blip of time they don't
have to but it gives them an option and
then if you incentivize them with
something maybe it's cool absolutely I
agree I think I think maybe bounties do
need to come back in some form because
again like maybe you can make make an
npc useful you know I'm saying God knows
that what's the ship name have to come
from her but you know to say like
they've got it they got to come from
saving her for spare racing if I
actually believed that I'd be happy but
I still don't know if that's ever coming
back so if you have if you could see
like a Bungie bullet like bulletin board
somewhere most of the priorities that's
way at the bottom right if they have now
smaller racing right now to community
would be like no like so you've been
working on Sparrow racing but we don't
like shooting work on priorities a
little bit so of course they're not
doing that and they're working but it's
just like again the misstep with the
night wolves why tech modifier is out
why remove the find why are you worried
about a score being skewed so say
everybody gets the nightfall aura
exactly two weeks you want people to
play that you know say you absolutely
went and I want to shout out real quick
on bretac is he made a great video about
the night phone it's like
another reason why the nightfall is in
the sense it is that's why I was so
bummed out about the note that specific
awards because because exotics and
everything are so plentiful right now
right no I know you get exotic doing
apology man you get exotic then and now
with all this you know extra rewarding
all the time that that was like their
quick fix Manny just reward them to
death just reward them you broke it and
then unfortunately it's like you're like
now they don't feel down they're not in
that exotic now there's no I miss Wynn
and like I said shadow CAG is one of his
recent videos like I miss when you
walked around town and you didn't see
like when you finally got your first one
you covered it I got my first look cuz
it didn't drop a lot but the thing that
always helped was I remember saying hey
I gotta run the night for this week for
a chance that one that was d1 on you
that was a chance for that Gjallarhorn a
chance for that ice break or whatever it
was they have to stop with the drop
rates being so high they have to stop
the three coins had to start with the
faded Engram I mean here don't records I
don't want that anymore
I don't even tell people to buy it
unless they're video which will really a
little while yeah yeah to me fated
engrams even worse because you literally
get through orangey is determining what
exactly you don't have so every week now
you go d'azyr he's gonna give you
everything you don't have you're gonna
have all the exotics so fast you can
have a Saturday with your milestones for
the week and you're gonna be about four
from that anyway it was like at least
yeah I agree I agree yeah so yeah I was
like one other piece in his article too
was and this is kind of what I was going
back to is like take what you have take
the content you've got and this is one
of the things he's saying that will fix
that will help build faith and bring
some people back is use the content you
have to make new content so he was
talking about basically it'd be like a
night fault here but basically take a
high level tier Patrol and give any
bosses out there
crank up the difficulty give a reason to
go do that you know have maybe a
different level of what like different
weapons that only come from doing that
stop stuff like patrol which is
basically used for flashpoint do your
and said I'm done you have these worlds
that you've built
Mercury's kind of small but the rest of
them are pretty decent-sized more yeah
it was a reason to go play around in
those like absolute it's like you know
see you've got you can see your map you
break it up into checkpoints you've like
you've got a mini boss here and if say
in the same landing zone you've got more
people you go through with your team and
you start picking these bosses off the
more of them you do without dying for
example you get a higher and higher to
your award which comes back to his other
pieces the rewards like if I say a
monster one more time you guys are
probably as you progress through the
game you get better and better gear
better and better weapons you're Kurt
your character literally never get
stronger unless you're wearing something
better or you're using a better weapon
that's literally how you get better as
what you use same thing we have gear it
makes you better our level is our level
could not exist at 20 or 25 and it would
not matter so that's neither here nor
there
um but yeah give us a redness kinda goes
back to the rewards mattering like
nightfall raids maybe it's that high
rate or high level high rank sub monster
hunt return but maybe it's a legendary
Patrol I think that could have been what
he called it give us certain things that
only come from there make them somewhat
difficult to get and make your power
level matter absolutely make the
activity the source of the reward
through a specific reward so that
encourages think about how much
engagement you get when the nightfall
again think about how much engagement
you get with the raid that's what's
gonna make people play that content over
and over again but make them play the
hard content that's how you solve it
it's really simple and again stuff they
not to beat a dead John with stuff that
they already existed yeah it's like just
they've got to take away like everybody
be enabled whatever and they probably
won't do it for amazing expansion within
year one but year two hey I would I
don't know how they could do it got an
erotic an advantage because I'm a beyond
what you're going you don't know what
you're doing they've already they're on
a slippery slope now because the
community so
pissed off right and the problem is we
we all agree that there's too many
reward sources like it's just way too
giving so at it's like I think if they
start taking stuff away even though I
would love it I would be like yes get
three coins out here yep get all the
stuff out of it like and bring it back I
think this I think they're so fearful of
the reaction that it's just gonna stay
and not these are the things and I have
a confession these are the things that
worry me about d2 ever coming back now
I'm not saying it's not piled in my
heart I feel they got one taken King
moment left in one moment cuz September
about me maybe too long for some but by
September all those systems that we want
you know randomized loose the mods and
all that stuff when we look at the dev
you know the development roadmap and we
sit down we like okay that's not that
worried me you know saying because it's
like you've got that that's your last
shot I'm a beat for D imma be brutally
honest and I'll still do these
flashpoints cuz I love the game so much
but it's just like you know if they
don't get it right by them and I know
even doc said that might be too late for
him yeah they've they've got a hint a
hope they've lived it's like they're
it's baseball it's the bottom of the
ninth you're down by like two three runs
people have going on to other games
that's not all got it got to knock it
out with the marketing the gameplay show
the community how much has changed so
much change but don't show me everything
you're gonna get right right absolutely
it's like I want to know the changes but
don't show me a full strike don't you
like keep it secret
absolutely it's nice to be hardness they
still have to be the light level stuff
but there has to be you know that
randomized loot all that stuff that
community wants and they've got to hit a
home run big they've got to pitch the
perfect game
they've got it's so much because the
minute you know randomize Luke's not
there the minute you know what
the Hilah stuff they will either
powerlevel you know in a minute that
stuff and in the rain has to be amazing
right that's another thing right the
rate not single vibing wasn't yeah
Leviathan was cool like and I like the
fine I'm talking about like either of
where else I'm you know don't get me
like what that wasn't terrible either
but it was short it was compact yeah I
was this small one-off kind of a thing
right they've got a knock it out because
man and all you see these new games come
in and think I know Activision said it
so unfortunately I probably bet that
will be before the end of the year but I
think it would serve them better to
spend more time fault like kind of like
let people fall I mean the people most
people have fallen off already so your
willingness to keep trying to push out
content barely get people back not make
big changes is not gonna make that big
of a difference they've really got to do
like they need to like rework so many
things yeah I was like honestly I don't
even care if it's March like if it's a
year from now for taking king 2.0 that's
a better time to really stuff typically
anyway because you start mm-hmm
September they shoot for for the
holidays but I feel like it's not enough
time for them to get the game in a state
that it's worth it then you review it
still you want it in that second half of
the year you've got Red Dead Redemption
- you've got whatever the battlefield is
you've got the fall releases of insanity
which everything steps on each other's
toes anyway if you try and if you creep
a little closer you have to push it back
all you do is get closer and closer to
that mess and people are like why am I
gonna do this when if I know I'm still
probably at least gonna play call it 80
yeah make you valid points you make it
funky okay I'll let you finish it was
like there's a CEO at Activision that's
gonna be like yeah and we promise
shareholders that so if you are gonna
bet a lot of money on a franchise do you
piss off shelter shareholders for a
little while but take more time to build
a game that's gonna hopefully bring them
back or do you feel it's already us I
mean I want to be I want to be in I
would I
I know it's a huge ass cause like making
the game and changing the systems is not
an easy thing and there's a lot of
things we're asking for because
it's not easy to build like hey put a
new boss in European dead zone and put a
couple different ones in each little
area and you've like hey you've got to
go through a couple waves like a horn
bump like there's so many things they
find a horde mode I'm like sitting there
going like yeah I wish but I was like
they had stuff like but even things he
[ __ ] documents and stuff like the
public event type archons force things
like those that don't exist anywhere I
don't know if that's something maybe
they have planned for or this you know
gods a Mars thing or whatever and that'd
be a way to do it but I mean at the end
of the day I feel what you're saying
take the time get it right the problem
that they have is they have the gun to
their head by Activision is for it's the
only game this is where I feel sorry for
them yeah it's the only game and I'm
gonna run it gave me a lot of money to
sorry but hey but it's the only game
where new content is consistently
demanded think about other games when
you play another game you know you get
your content you get it packaged and
that's it you play it you're done
destiny has different requirements
because of the ravenous community
because we go through the content so
fast right so it's like even if the
content is amazing they have to keep
looking ahead looking ahead what's the
next thing what's the next one what's
the next thing and the problem is if
they it's already the player count and
the player base is so low now compared
to you know what it should be and howdy
one was that if my fear is if they push
that back out of September and say hey
let's wait until next spring or whatever
whatever
I mean it's go both ways I could I could
see a situation when people be like out
of sight out of mind that the in
non-existence dead I'm done or maybe
they have a Rainbow six siege moment
where it's like I remember Rainbow six
siege came out people like oh no this is
not here this is not what I wanted yada
yada yada they took time off they got it
right and then you know I'm saying at
the end of the day they brought it back
in such a great state that it in the
neck they had like a free which I know
destiny would never do but like they had
like a free you know Rainbow six is free
for the weekend
right and they make they could had a
free play right had all these people
come back to test it right after they
made all the patches all this whatever
whatever and then right then rainbow I
never I remember it like it was just
saying that following week after the
weekend that Tuesday they dropped an
expansion and it was a pain but it was
really good in conjunction with the
passions and the fixes they did so maybe
they can go that route you know I'm
saying because I've seen it out there
I've seen people say like the game so
bad how dare you charge me for another
expansion right now yeah so it can be
better you know it's a tough one it's a
tough one man yeah like I am it's just
like when as much fun as I've had then I
see stuff like Chrono Trigger coming I'm
like I'd love to go back to that but
then it's like but I still I still want
to play destiny there's a desire to
still be in that world because it's one
that I've it's been part of my world for
three and a half years now mm-hmm you
want to keep going but it's like if we
have no incentive and it's the shifts
kind of kept going towards that indie
one like the iron banner you'd get up to
max level and it's like iron banner was
not literally as just time it's not
skill right and I mean go to something
else like there were there were
basically as you progress through in
Monster Hunter there's certain levels
you get through you'll go through you're
like okay I got you know my first basic
weapon I've created a little bit I'm
going through I can take most of these
out okay this guy just kicked my butt
like I'm not even close
okay I know I've got to go through grind
work on some things maybe get little
pieces here and there okay I finally got
through here and working through working
through crap there's another wall it's
like there's the feeling of progression
is so like kindergarten here you go
in this game yeah that there's no
feeling of it's rare and that's why I
was like I want to go through a
nightfall solo because I it's that's one
of the few things that actually still
gives me that feeling of accomplishment
right and that word of accomplishment is
one that like you have to work for it
like you should have to want to work for
the highest stuff and it's there there's
none of that right now if you just play
around you do your basic things you go
do public events which you could
literally just shoot
enemy and stand around and not die and
get your awards though the ways you
could get the things as opposed to
happen to be on your game to do the
highest level stuff it just takes away
the you know the feel of a need to you
know the want to do anything harder like
you can do the easy stuff and be done
agreed completely agreed that that's the
it the way it is currently set up is
literally what should you say that you
know you get everything and then you're
done and that's what happens child to
Chris go buddy Lee yes like you if
there's no incentive because you've got
everything you did what else is there to
come back to you know so again they've
they've gotta figure out I don't envy
the position that they're in know it's a
tough one I can only imagine with those
meetings on behind closed doors I can
only imagine the pressures they have you
know it's I mean yes it was based on the
initial sales testing to was a
tremendous success it's like top three
and 2017 just on sales for the year but
since then you know I don't know if
you've been checking and check out peas
we well I saw blood Pacifica same trials
is lower than it's ever been for d1 and
then still keeps going down here's
what's even worse besides that you know
one Iowa podcast we do every month we do
the MPD's you know I mean and you know
when I really hate me I think I thought
we had the the dude on we had to dude
let me now shout out to him for short
quick short pause podcast and he's a
hardcore destiny guy like us yeah and
his channel is actually founded on that
and he brought it to my attention it and
a light bulb went off he said or kognito
look at that top 10 MPD software list
PlayStation Xbox top 10 it destiny to
wasn't even in the top 10 that is
unheard of from a sales perspective
getting hit in the wallet because even
in d1 you know during the whole phase of
what was it a crota
what was that will expansion dark-blue
dr. Loe
sc2 was like you know maybe five six
seven it was still selling don't give
like now it's like the words out and
they if people are abandon it like the
play it's not even
sellin some of the games that were above
it I was just like wow and I'm like I
said what you know I'm gonna give you
guys think I'll give you a sneak peek in
creamy right now we're gonna have um
hopefully we're gonna have one of the
MPD guys on the show on LP and this is
gonna be one of the questions I asked
them because um the that's that's
troubling now Activision has to has to
jump in like you they're not making
money anymore after those initial one or
two months sales and when the PC
launched of course but yeah it's
interesting man I was like and you've
got stuff like pub G you've got for
tonight that's popular you're gonna have
more games that come out mm-hmm and if
you just try and make it too casual
you're gonna blow through it too quick
you have to end it it's like the
incentive to play the game is gone for
so many people it's gone and they're
just like I've got too many other
options why am I gonna if I'm 335 like
you can't and that's the thing is even
if you're 335 nearly hey I want to do my
milestones that's all I have for the
weekend they can be done in a couple
hours on Tuesday and you're done and
then six other days out of the week
you're like man what it would be like
you got a friend like what do you want
to play well I only play destiny like
once a week but I don't play that much
anymore so let's try this other thing
like the communication is not there to
be like dude I'm still playing trials
let's do that this weekend you need to
pick it up and grind up and get up here
with me and it's just it's not there I
agree I know I think we can probably
have that that horse is officially dead
we would go all four hours on that one I
mean the wrap-up is just kind of the
feel the way you feel after like hey we
got a big failure patch is this the one
no no I can tell you from most as not a
lot of people are hoping for March then
you've got a break for April for
marketing and stuff for the expansion
and all that stuff's gonna be announced
pre e3 and then May as expansion is
whatever's next but yeah even for Mays
expansion man I wonder what the numbers
are gonna be like there may be a blip
for like a week maybe two for people to
blow through it yeah but it's that if it
doesn't change that much it's not gonna
last long I agree and the only other
counter I was just taking off off the
top is it's gotta be a significant light
increase as well because it more than 30
yeah it's gotta be because you
people engage you know I mean misto $500
care seriously that probably number
sorry but yeah honestly like make
something that big so you actually feel
like you've got to work first off for a
little while absolutely and if you put
that and make power matter
you had that trials those requirements
and trials iron banner in the raid girl
no you told now you give people like yo
I got it I got to do this in order to
get in that new reign I got to do this
you know if they like I say if they fix
the gameplay stuff between now and then
you figure what April main when that DLC
or drop you know and then you throw that
in there with a high light level that
high character chase cuz if it's like
what is it what are we now what is it if
it's like 365 we're almost to jump
before that you're 35 what was myself or
335 on the base game 305 so well you
went up stuck it's 300 to 330 and then
you've got mods right yeah it's gotta be
more than that big fear was there was a
blip at some point was like hey what's
the expansion is it gonna be 350 and we
got 330 so it's literally 20 more for a
full expansion no play enough I'm gonna
blaze through that will blaze do that
about a week two weeks yeah and I wish
we could feel powerful ever I know they
balance things so you you don't feel too
much like a god but that's part of the
fun of any game with progression if I go
if I go do a normal nightfall at 270 and
the prestige nightfall at 3:30 and I'm
333 for example or 335 or 332 that
normal nightfall should be a challenge
but it should not kick my butt the way a
330 should angry that's one thing I wish
I wish I wish because it's parently my
week for it but if I go back and I go I
go whence I go help my brother in
Monster Hunter and he was on low level
and I've been playing high level stuff
for a little while so I'm I'm a buff I'm
like I'm pretty good
I'm not epic but I'm solid and he's
starting out but I go help him with a
monster ice
the crap out of that thing in like 60
seconds but I was like I we never get
that feeling we never get to go back and
play stuff and feel powerful
it still dyin patrols normal low-level
patrols I'm like I did those at level
like for lying now I'm clearly not scary
you're right you're supposed to have
that feeling of power and don't get me
wrong not that I'm calling for the raids
not to level but remember in d1 like it
felt good sometimes they go back into an
old raid you know I'm saying yeah trust
me I don't want them to keep low old
raids at low light levels I'm not saying
that I'm just saying the feeling that
you got when you actually did jumping in
and you were like yeah more powerful you
know say like one of the few times you
actually felt more powerful if you went
back to like 160 vault I'm really but
yeah and faster it feels like yeah I
remember asking in the or sleep of
stimulates and just know my fealty Oh
miss sleeping with yes that's that's I
think the only way they fix it is
they've got to give you a progression
system that makes you know makes you
actually that lets you feel powerful
have a progression system that's not too
easy and then have activities in the
game that use your content in different
ways yeah so I mean just use it all out
there it's like so however long that
takes you to make I mean I'm okay
waiting because between now and then I
know like pyro is another one of the
YouTube guys that I follow likes out at
the pound I like his stuff he's always
solid he's great guy too
he's waiting on spider-man he was gonna
drop everything when that PlayStation
Spiderman comes out he is playing that
there's just more and more games so if
you want to win them back you got to do
it big and you got to do it right yeah
thanks
amen so well that's probably enough of
us rambling for the week I mean
sometimes you guys may be like hey it's
venting but it's like they're all things
we want I think you guys too so we're
just trying to vocalize many of the
thoughts that you know Doc's got those
he examine his article he gets those out
there this is our venue to get ours out
there as well so and we
Bungie listens and honestly for their
sake I hope Activision can not getting
their way not that way and not force
them to do something exactly it was like
if I know Activision has shareholders
they've got a lot of money and it's like
in their stock prices and CEOs you guys
it's like I know you're talking about oh
I'm losing or winning millions you're
still fine in the grand scheme it's like
so
but in if you got a look long-term you
can't look current cash cow right and
that's and if you want long-term you
want this to be a franchise if you burn
it now it's gonna be rough absolutely
because right now you know what happens
with d2 affects d3 I've seen the
comments I've seen people say hey
they're like I'm yeah I don't know about
d3 how dare they even talk about d3
until this is I've seen that common you
know narrative and rhetoric so this this
is like I said this year all the way up
to September critical critical critical
critical for the law and my opinion and
I'm being bullion it's for the long-term
health of the destiny franchise I really
think it's that serious no I do too you
may have a Diablo 3 moment when a Diablo
3 drop that loop patch and change the
way things were played and revitalize
they have to have a taken king moment
they cannot continue to do what they're
doing no get me wrong these baby steps
are cool I'm saying but it has to be a
complete revamp if they stick to their
guns and they like no we're gonna keep
the the weapons not randomized no we're
gonna keep you know you know primary
yeah tough if that thing won't win it
you won't get anybody in the back you're
not so we can see what happens this is a
very interesting time but we are the
recorders of history we will I would
sadly take a bet now with you further
preferred with whatever we meet up or
something like that if taking king 2.0
ish is I think forced and pushed out and
those changes aren't there it may be it
may be like I don't know I would I would
be happier with the game later
so my
is if it's if we get taken king 2.0 in
September I don't think it's gonna be
what people want mmm this is a good hood
I don't buzz like so if it's September I
don't think it's gonna have I don't
think it's gonna be enough okay so let
me let me quantify your bet though okay
what does it need to be in your opinion
like how far can the pushback spring of
2019 late that's I'd be happy if it was
there because the I mean okay you're
that you're saying no I'm just saying I
think if it's not saying like when it
comes later I'm saying if it launches
he's gonna September if if taking King
2.0 or whatever it is is that September
date the destiny seems to hold if it's
it will not get reviewed well not last
long and it will not be the game that
people want and therefore it's it's
gonna say you're something with
intelligence you're speaking with a lot
of facts
everything is let's be fit like let's
drill this bet favors you this definite
I'm gonna go against it but you don't
know I was just gonna say and you don't
even have to because sadly when you look
at the calendar which I'm looking for
the link to it somewhere in here they
have stuff that they're saying right
here it's on the screen so season 3 and
then they mentioned stuff way back
before stuff that they wanted and fall
and it's just like some stuff is coming
sooner like Rumble maybe they're but man
stuff they were thinking about stuff for
being there
I don't it's like if it's not I don't
know if they if they managed to get all
that stuff in there before or at least
with lunch it's got a shot he's been off
my he's my kind of bit to you I love
this I love this victim alive a kiss
efficient all right I'm with you however
here's my bet dagger I say they can save
it the September right but I have a
caveat okay yeah straight if the weapon
did whole you know first of all the rep
the randomized loot like if randomized
loot comes in a certain form like a mod
or whatever whatever and if if that's
not there or if um the other thing is
not there
beyond the actual what is it you know
the primarily okay right so weapon slot
allocation randomized loop right yeah
without though those are the two those
are the two you gotta have right now if
there's no combination of those two I
agree with you if they say that they can
meet that deadline I'm gonna stick and
stand by them coming in September and
and saving the game if they can those
two requirements because to me that's
the thing I've heard they were like I
can't randomize rules I get the fifth
better Devils what's the point
yeah and that's that was addressed even
when they announced destiny to and they
said they're working on it apparently
they're still working on it
and then since e3 is like launch
discussion we're nine months later and
we don't have a clue what to do with our
fifth one like if you throw that promise
out in the air I mean I mean Luke Smith
made some awesome stuff but if you're
gonna throw it in the air you've got to
follow through yeah absolutely
you got to knock it out you got to knock
it out so that's my thing if they can
put those two in I think September they
can save I can see and ill marketing
push come on
III cuz you know they're gonna be on a
Sony stage they're gonna have to show
something right no compacts they got to
show something for this upcoming DLC cuz
pax is April they have shows something
but I'm not worried about I don't think
that's gonna be enough I would agree
desk
September's the key and they don't then
yeah I can't no that's that's I mean we
don't have to bet per se because I think
we both have the same cavity just like
there's not major major changes to these
systems of destiny to for a September
release it won't be enough and people
look at and be like yell be more story
maybe it's disconnect and we had that
whole tangent last week maybe it's more
story if you know maybe PvP feels a
little better maybe that some of its
there but it's like it won't hold it
won't last if those were animals all
that stuff's not there random roles and
just the weapons now I heard another
like random thing somewhere what would
you think of a fourth weapon slot I
wouldn't be opposed to that
so you have
primary in elemental a special kind of
like in d1 and then a heavy yeah I was
like however they do it if it's that or
you have primary special like if they
they like the double but it's easier to
add a second one they learn you moves
right positions down to slot forever you
do that great and then you give grenade
launchers a huge freaking buff because
you have you they have to compete with
rocket launcher those nobody's going to
use them because they're a similar
explosive type thing you have to give
them something and compat ammo
capacities not it because they're a
heart as hell dame yeah so i was like a
force something like a fourth slot to
change the way it feels random roles and
you know in game level 600 plate you
make it big and grant like that again I
can see it holding its own for longer
and also and also strike specific loot
ah you know I'm saying like you can't be
you got a itch litter I want my my grasp
of my lock moments right you want that
those helmets you know what you call its
hood know like like all those unique
start like you told again you got it
they've got to do so much you know I'm
saying you need you the outbreak prime
style raid you know you just it's down
you know quest stuffy they all the
secrets all the lore the stuff that you
had to really work hard to get indeed
one that made you stand out the Oren's
gotta be they've gotta go so balls to
the wall like the I'm tell you it's
literally you know that that you know
bottom of the ninth you're down by two
whatever it is you've got to hit that
you gotta hit like a three run home run
great almost a grand slam you've got to
do that to get everyone back I have
confidence at marketing team oh one
thing I will say about desi even with
open high they get there the Masters a
high all they had at me thinking curse
of Osiris is gonna be like Joe I I got
confidence in the marketing team I know
those dudes and the artists get busy
okay uh I got I got a I got a little
inkling here let's go
now we finally face the darkness no I'm
serious if you want to give you one d2
you got to go big and you got to give
them that villain that new enemy and you
got to go for the thing that has been
talked about for four years if you're
saving it for destiny three-man pull out
the big you got to pull the big guns now
you have to go all out and then if it
takes you longer to get to get d3 I
don't care but like if that you get it
yes you're saying you're gonna hit for
the fences and you got to get like that
you know world record Grand Slam 550
footer just I don't care like just blow
it away and that's for me why I don't
think they can fit it by September mm
that's why I was like all those things
we want I would rather see it come out
like destiny - I don't even know what
you call it like cuz it was you know
dusty took taken King so just need to
take in Queen flower you and I have good
joke that that's outside with concept
art of that strike but yeah it's like if
it's I would you can still market it and
do it later
enough destiny people will still follow
people will still hype it they don't
talk to Game Informer
what's the GameStop magazine yeah it's
Game Informer head of him have them do a
cover maybe it's not September but it's
like after people have faded off do that
was like a February cover what else are
you playing right now I mean we're
playing some random stuff this if you
don't do it September you got to do it
like very much no yeah you sell them
you're selling me a little bit about
saying a lot because even let's just say
it is great and it is amazing
October is right at redemption that's
the problem we'll hold on and if it's
got online people will play Auto
November November is Call of Duty do as
to how we feel about Zod it still sells
it's it's Zod yeah yeah like however
stupid million people are just like yeah
I'm playing the new code you have to do
a push back yeah you may have to do a
push back to February March bite the
bullet really go hard
February marks that begin of the years
always you got time now you kind of
finished all your holiday releases we
got like a monster hunter now we've got
you know you'll get you'll get a monster
hunter you'll get a kingdom come you'll
get things like the witness you'll get
blood-borne you'll get cool stuff but
it's not at that level and if somebody
triple-a took like was like sup February
you're mine like not a lot of that tier
is gonna come out to compete I think and
it gives you spring summer like I don't
know how that does and I know you got
money but it's just like wait a couple
months like I don't know I think that
was I'm just worried I can't see
activision no and that's my worries
Activision I mean and it's not a worry
it's it's publishers and investors and
things like that and it'll answer to
people and it's like and I know that's
how that goes but if you want to go
long-term I think you have to go bigger
and it takes yeah no you're right you're
right now you with me over I was like I
mean it's I was like there's gonna be
it's like you got yours especial it's
like it can go both ways absolutely but
it's just that's my feeling is it won't
be enough even they can't get enough
done then
and I'm not saying bungees not talented
it's because we're asking for so we're
asking for so much yeah and it's you're
almost rewriting destiny to you have to
rework so many systems and then I talk
about those system level changes little
things touch so much when they talk
about the code changes they're like
that's a code fix as opposed to a
different level fix like the code fixes
touch a lot of systems in the game and
they're gonna make sure they're square
like that's just next time like it does
but I mean according to the development
row back by May we're gonna well they're
not gonna have then I could have read
about it I could have yet they have any
mention that stuff though that's I would
if they even mention that I like be like
alright guys we know we haven't fixed
the loop we are working on randoms like
people be like oh [ __ ] just like it
would just like they'd lose their crap
play use it they lose it and that would
just be like hey you know that'll keep
people a little more in tune to be like
okay so when it when it does happen we
gonna get a new game and it feels like
we almost need not destiny 3 but almost
it needs to be like taken away from what
people have like again so alright well
our time will be taken up
I went way over we went crazy today guys
know if you go if you want to talk about
this you too we can ramble for a while
but we should probably wrap up here for
now
X the next week is gonna be iron banner
so you guys can go after those you know
ornaments if you want are probably
waiting for that March 27 watch what he
said one point one point fall let's go
baby can I get that in like meme for me
Yogi Bear a little bit it's coming guys
but as you can tell it's like we know
there's a lot of work that needs done so
we'll just have to see what comes I'm
kind of curious to see what little story
comes out of eater of or gods of Mars or
whatever that's gonna be called but in
the meantime yeah enjoy it if you do if
you're not have fun and other things and
we'll keep you guys in tune to what the
destiny world is doing sorry about our
tangents about a half hour of actual
content coverage and a half hour of hope
but you know kind of have some hope out
there so from the pageanty place man
let's wrap this thing up all my first
ones a shout out for you I'll head out
Oh Chris Cobra leading the chat man he's
been riding with us all the way through
all much thank you so much for John we
know this is a passion project in you
know saying we just try and let the
community know what needs to what needs
to be said and also you know what what
we want and there's also letting people
know because there's still a lot of
people that love destiny and they're
just like hey is it okay to come back
yet yet so for right now was no but like
I said March 27th a big a big thing
coming up there big step we got may you
know and then we'll see how the gear
goes on but we're gonna be in a box we
gonna we like to stenographers the
destiny we don't we gonna document
everything make our comments we'll talk
about it but uh yeah lord Cognito him do
the outros
you can find me on the arc on twitter at
ball Cognito on xbox live at at laura
Cognito on our playstation I'm actually
a cognitive 360 and yeah before look out
for the
watch podcast this Sunday that is
searchable 1:00 p.m. Eastern Standard
Time
you know I'm saying we're gonna have a
big guest still working on the details
with that and um also that's gonna be on
the inner circle Network still gonna be
doing flashpoints here on the iron lost
podcast letter as well as a bot assist
channel at least please check his
channel out still if you're looking out
for DES key content as well so yeah a
box is to get your outro goin brethren
Sam is here yeah just think with destiny
I'm working on Monster Hunter as well
and just as as time goes guys I still
will do destiny content don't worry I'm
not going anywhere but I do I want to
have some fun too and you know it's not
saying destiny to isn't fun but other
games are fun too so I'm gonna have a
little more variety you guys have heard
me talk about Monster Hunter a lot if
you spend 150 hours in a game it's a lot
of fun I wanted to spend a long time in
the game to get comfortable that talked
to you guys about it so now I'm kind of
getting to the point where I feel like I
can talk a little more intelligently it
takes us to get there but yep so more
content will be coming guys follow me be
gameplay I'm gonna go try and do a
nightfall solo sometime tonight or this
weekend so I can see if I can not going
out see how much how much I want to do
but outside of that guys you know where
to find me on Twitter comm Montes
twitch.tv slash Yvonne says and just
right here on YouTube guys iron Lords
podcast check them out Sunday's always
good stuff in there good guest good chat
always good commentary and this right
here on my my channel as well just if
you guys haven't subscribed hit that
subscribe button please bosses like
respect its respect man even when it's
for a while great content man great
content and some of the most salacious
night falls and content in such calm
refreshing I've been told Blake yeah
I've had a couple comments about Maya
just kind of the way I deliver this like
I'm just calming collected usually as I
am I was doing my night falls before and
as I'm sitting there going through
shooting stuff I was like I was turned
in mine into a destiny to have
commentary I was like I gotta pull it
back so yeah you'll get a little bit of
everything in those gotta usually I'm
not the big crazy outspoken yelling
people I'm usually gonna be a little
more calm giving you guys heads up on
how to work your way through so
good mommy all right well as always
where have you guys are at around the
world good afternoon good morning or
good evening have a good one peace 1.1
people